hi my name is euro and i'm a software
and machine learning engineer here in
switzerland and i work for a company a
small company that i co-founded a few
years ago
i think what i what i liked the most was
um it had it had like the the right
depth to get started in machine learning
um
it was pretty pretty broad so it wasn't
specific about computer vision or nlp
was everything in there
and also
uh it wasn't just about theory um it was
really like hands-on experience so you
you got a piece of information and you
you were able to process it in a sense
you'll be able to train models and
really see what comes out of it
models like
you know train models audio audio models
where
you produce you know
jazz music or
you do you know
style transfer
i learned how to
read kind of specific information paper
or get idea
and basically make it work make it make
it you know coded together
and
have something executable that does
produce some useful results and
those were the first step basically in
getting getting in touch with what
really ai is what machine learning
really is
andrew is capable of you know breaking
down complex concepts into you know
small and simple pieces and explain it
to anybody in a way that you really
understand it and
and are able to actually code it
[Applause]
[Music]